♪ Oh j'
Tout le monde!
♪ J'veux plus rien savoir ♪
- Paolo Noël aura charmé et fait
danser toute une génération.à le
lorsqu'impmpmporte
un concours d'imitation.
Dès les années 50, il fait ses
prrerererererererererererererere
ses premières chansons.
Rapidement, Poeoeoeoël gagne
le coeur du public et anime
des émissions de radio et de
télévision dicicicicicicicicici.
DOMINIQUE MICHEL
humoriste et comédienne
- J'ai travaillé avec lui
été agréable, c'était un bon
gars. C'était... il avait...unun
finalement dans la vie.
♪ Catherina ♪
succès grâce aux reprises
de chansons comme "Catherina
ou encore "J'avais 20 ans".
♪ Pour les yeux d'une femme ♪
Pgagagagagagagagagagagagagagag,
ce sera le fil conducteur
n n n n n de ses chansons.
♪e,e,e,e,e,e,e,e,e,e,e,e,e,e,e,,
Diane Bolduc, à ses côtés
plplplplplus de 50 ans.
Espiègle et farceur,
une anecdote à raconter.
- Paolo Noël s'illu
- Tu parles à Tony Potenza!
- On le vo
dans la série "Omerta".
LUC DIONNE
scénaris o o o o o o o o o o o t
demandé s'il voulait participer
à s s s s s serait intéressé par
un rôle. Ça faisait très
joué devant les caméras.
Évidemment, il a accepté
proposition et à partir de
bonheur, les fous rires sur
le plateau.
- Au grand écran, il joue
dans quelques films dont
"Les immortels", "Les doigts
♪ C'est si bon de t'aimer ♪
En 2015, après une
carrière de plus de 65 ans
Paolo Noël tire sa révérence.
♪ Je n'aime que toi ♪ F F F F F,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
chchchchchchche pas
à me comprendre ♪
♪ Puisque ma vie